get introductions
if you're having a hard time marketing
your product one of my favorite ways to
grow a business is to get introductions
to people who are my potential customers
instead of me trying to go out there
knock on doors or cold call them because
they probably won't be interested you
got to hit them at the right time and
with a warm introduction if you do that
then you dramatically increase the
chances of you closing the deal i got a
comment from my youtube video viewer
uh
shaki shakui hope i pronounce that
properly anyways in the clothing
business wants to market his clothing
samples wants to know what to do to get
his name out there should they go knock
on retail stores and just go visit them
and tell them about his product or what
should he do is confuse
and my best advice here
is to go out and try to get somebody who
can help make those warm introductions
for you
it's so much easier they have the
contacts and the sale comes almost
instantly if it comes from a
recommendation from somebody who they
know like and trust
i know at the beginning it's really hard
to
to get that to happen right if you don't
have any contacts how do you build it up
how do you start from scratch
that was me when i had my first business
i knew nobody
i barely had anybody to support me in
what i was doing like like friends and
family a few who actually believed in
what i was doing but they didn't have
any contacts to help me i didn't know
where to start
i had to start from like scratch from
nothing
so what i did
and maybe you could do it a little
faster than how long it took me
i went and to my banker like i know
nobody i don't even know my banker but i
have a bank account so like at least the
lease talked to me and i went to talk to
my banker and
i said here's what i'm trying to do i
don't i don't know if i need money i
don't really know what i'm doing uh i'm
looking for some contacts what do you
think can you help me out
and
luckily i had a nice enough banker who
liked me
and believed in what i was trying to do
there was passion for my business
and he offered to connect me with a
consultant that the bank had used before
now i couldn't afford a consultant but i
was happy to meet with him to see if he
had any ideas
and i met up with this consultant he had
this great downtown office you know
dressed in a full suit this guy was
money
but he didn't really understand what i
did he spoke a good game but he didn't
really understand what i did so he
brought in a friend of his
who also was similar background i always
wore suits and and smoke a really good
game again but also didn't really
understand what we did
and so he brought in another friend
this guy's name was john
who got what we did
who understood building up technology
companies and selling them and who had a
lot of contacts so he could introduce us
to
and we ended up working with him and not
with anybody else that i spoke with at
the beginning
and that made a huge difference for my
business it opened up huge doors for me
that i didn't have access to before
and so instead of me knocking on
people's doors and saying hey buy my
product it's something really great
and just trying to compete with
everybody else he opened up the doors
for us because he already had a lot of
contacts and they would listen to him
because they knew him liked him trusted
him
and the path to finding john
is hard to replicate
right and on on
the surface seems
strange
at least for me to be able to say it but
but it works and you can do it
i knew nobody right i started from
scratch i went to my bank
thinking that banks were supposed to be
the friends of entrepreneurs right
we all know that story
and i had to go through two other people
after the bank who
weren't the right fit for me and i
almost gave up hope like doesn't anybody
understand what i'm trying to do can
anybody out there really help me
and that's when we met john
and so keep reaching and and you can
start even if you know nobody you start
by telling some of the people who you do
have a contact with
even if it's a distant contact like a
bank or like a lawyer like an accountant
let them know what you're trying to do
and who you're looking for and they may
pass you on to somebody who may pass you
on the subject and maybe pass you on to
somebody else who pass you on the person
who can really help you open up the
doors that you need
keep building your company keep trying
to market it
but the best way to be able to do it at
this stage for you is really to get
somebody to help you open up those doors
and mentor you along the way
believe
for those of you watching like the video
give it a thumbs up below and i'd love
to hear what you have to think leave a
comment underneath i'll make a video
response for you thank you so much and
i'll see you soon
you